sur 2010 vers la grosse émission
mais nous sommes 300 personnes passent
en justice avec le maire je sais pas
maintenant je le vois c'est vrai j'ai vu
il y en a d'autres qui en a d'autres
moins drôle que vous mais bon
sa défense il
a retourné la balle belle ambiance
qu'est ce que vous avez dit cordis on
vous a dit ça à rien bon alors non mais
vous êtes vraiment en ce moment ça
marche pour vous un bon puisque sur les
filles quoi pas on peut linda que j'ai
vu hors plus et l'ami travers de deux
parce que je viens de belfort 90 c'est
vrai c'est la non mais c'est pas de
nouvelle fois je me suis dit que c'était
pour toi pour moi que tu avais mis ça
non c'est aussi pour toi d'abord nice et
port bou et puis parce qu'aussi linda
voulait montrer à notre public à nos
amis du samedi soir qu'elle avait pris
un peu de ça tu en as pris trop un réel